exclusive interview with billionaire
philanthropy philanthropist Melinda
French Gates last May French Gates and
Microsoft co-founder Bill Gates stunned
the world when they announced that they
were ending their 27-year marriage for
decades the pair appeared to be the
perfect example of a power couple giving
back after splitting up they still share
that commitment and they are maintaining
a working relationship they jointly run
their Foundation which currently manages
an endowment of about 50 billion dollars
for the first time since that
announcement frenchgate sat down with us
for a wide-ranging interview about her
journey of healing and her next chapter
in life
divorce is a painful process even when
it's what both parties want it still is
a very painful personal decision but
most divorces I think aren't on Evening
News it's not a topic of conversation
did you think when you and Bill release
that statement that it would be a
national conversation
first of all I think you know I want to
say that on the day I got married I
never thought I would end up being
divorced never you really did think till
death do us part it did and um you know
unfortunately I felt like I I needed to
take a different path and so I think you
know we knew that when the divorce was
going to be announced that it would be a
surprise to people and I felt bad about
that but I probably I didn't have any
sense of how big of news it would be you
never you can't anticipate something
like that after the news came out it was
revealed that Bill Gates admitted that
he had had an affair in the marriage and
at that time did you think we're going
to work through this how did you handle
something like that
well I certainly believe in forgiveness
so I thought we had worked through some
of that it wasn't one moment or one
specific thing that happened there just
came a point in time where there was
enough there that I really just wasn't
healthy and I couldn't trust what we had
there was one report that said it was
multiple Affairs do you care to say
anything about that you know I think
those are questions bill needs to answer
okay
you know it was also widely reported
that Bill had a friendship or business
or some kind of contact with Jeffrey
Epstein and that you were not that that
was very upsetting to you did that play
a role in the in the divorce at all in
this process yeah as I said it's not one
thing it was many things but I did not
like uh that he'd had meetings whichever
Epstein now
and you made that clear to him I made
that clear to him I also met Jeffrey
Epstein exactly one time did you yes
because I wanted to see who this man was
and
um
I regretted it from the second I stepped
in the door he was abhorrent he was evil
personified I had nightmares about it
afterwards so you know my heart breaks
for these young women because that's how
I felt and here I'm an older woman my
God I feel terrible for those young
women it's awful you felt that the
moment you walked out
yeah and you shared that with Bill and
he still continued to spend time with
him
any of the questions remaining about
what Bill's relationship there was those
are for Bill to answer okay but I made
it very clear how I felt about him I
think so many times when women go
through a divorce they feel ashamed or
they feel they did something wrong
especially when it's so public so many
women question themselves what did I do
was this my fault did you have any of
that I don't question myself now not at
all
I gave
every single piece of myself to this
marriage I was committed to this
marriage on the day we got engaged and
until the day I got out of it
so no but I also think Society used to
put things on women like it was our
fault no I did nothing wrong so I hold
my head high did you have moments where
you were just so angry did you have
moments that you were just in such pain
because people look at you Melinda
French Gates and say she has it all she
has it all well I think it's really
important to say look I had a lot of
Tears for many days I mean days where
I'm literally laying on the floor in the
carpet you know this close to me
thinking
how can this be how can I get up how am
I going to move forward in days I
certainly was angry I mean this is
painful stuff and at the end of the day
though I started on this journey of
healing and I feel like I'm starting to
get to the other side and I do feel like
I'm I'm turning a page in the chapter
now I mean it's 2022 and I'm actually
really excited about what's to come in
life ahead for me how would you describe
your relationship with Bill Gates today
I don't even know if relationship is the
right word I don't know the word well we
certainly have a working relationship
right and I would say we're friendly at
this point
friends
friends is a different word for me and
you know that might come over time but
for me uh there's still healing that
needs to to happen certainly I wish him
well I don't wish him harm
um and I think we have a productive
working relationship and I think that
will continue
Melinda frenchgate says she'll keep
working with her former husband At The
Gates Foundation which they co-founded
together more than 20 years ago as she
works to grow her own company pivotal
Ventures do you feel very grounded when
you're here because that's how I feel
walking in the door I just feel really
it's just a very calming space where
she's focused on funding projects that
Empower women you are the recipients and
the winners of a 10 million dollar
equality can't wait to Grant and for
French Gates philanthropy is Paramount
she started the giving pledge with Bill
Gates and Warren Buffett back in 2010
was a call to arms for the world's
wealthiest to give away a majority of
their worth in her latest giving pledge
letter she writes this
giving away money your family will never
need is not an especially Noble act you
appear to be putting as the kids of
today say rich people on blast because
you said I recognize the absurdity of so
much wealth being concentrated in the
hands of one person I believe the only
responsible thing to do with the fortune
is to give it away were you challenging
other billionaires well I do believe
that if you are lucky enough to be a
billionaire believe me you can give away
half of it and not change your life and
we should we should have a society where
if for whatever reason wealth is in your
hands you you put it back in society so
that you change and you lift up others
but I also like too in the letter you
point out and you want to do more than
just write checks oh yeah that's not
good enough for you just to write a
check not for me now some people do that
there's lots of ways to do philanthropy
and that's great but I I need to see it
and feel it like I cannot wait till this
summer where I feel like I can probably
go back to several African countries and
it won't be covid will hopefully be
enough behind us that it won't be
disruptive I want to be out talking to
people I want to see the work because
it's in seeing and listening we have to
listen to people
they have their own Solutions in their
community and if we listen sometimes
it's just a matter of saying oh my gosh
okay they've got the way to keep the
water clean let's just fund what they
know will work today frenchgate says
she's looking ahead in all areas of her
life I always believe Melinda in order
to move forward you have to get through
and you seem to either have gotten
through or you're still getting through
what is it I think it's a bit of both I
think I've probably gotten through the
hardest times not that there haven't
been some hard times even in the last
two weeks
I do my very best to show up as my best
self are you open to Falling in Love
again and dating are you open to that
definitely definitely are yeah yeah I
hope that happens for me again you know
I'm dipping my toe in that water a
little bit you are yeah and um you know
what does the water look like Melinda
interesting does it I'll say interesting
at this point really yeah why not look
at that smile yeah Melinda as someone
who you described in the beginning as
her cheek on the floor you seem to be in
a really good place today thank you I I
feel like I'm in a really good place and
I'm really really excited about my life
and about the world the work ahead
now in a statement to CBS News Bill
Gates said meeting with Epstein was a
mistake that I regret deeply it was a
substantial error in judgment both Bill
and Melinda say they remain dedicated to
working together at the Gates Foundation
friendly but not necessarily friends
yeah yeah very interesting distinction
there is but you know she was such a
Class Act guys she is so lovely and so
full of grace and this was not an
interview to demon eyes or trash Bill
Gates I think she chose her words very
carefully but she was very candid but
she wanted people to know she did this
interview because she said I want people
to know I'm moving on with my life I've
closed that chapter I'm moving on it was
painful yes but I'm moving on and she is
a whole full grown ass woman ready ready
to move on to do good in this world and
she's going by French Gates now I guess
that's deliberate right yeah yeah well
that is her maiden name because she said
listen it's the name of my children it's
the name of the foundation which is
deeply ingrained in Her Bones that's why
she's keeping Gates yes and she's not
mad at the name Gates right she's not
mad at the name Gage you know but you
know she is in a really good place and
it was just really good to see her that
way and I'm happy she's ready to move on
and find new love she said she's dipping
her toe in that water can't you see
people say Melinda my number is there's
a lot of swimmers out there with
floaties on you in that water I'm diving
in there's a lot of stuff floaties on
here disqualified
gotta know how to swim huh yeah that's
very good Nate